Paula Paula que está en juego en estas
elecciones bueno en estas elecciones
está en juego la democracia está en
juego la confianza hacia las
instituciones no podemos olvidar que el
presidente bolsonaro y hoy candidato
bolsonaro pues ha puesto en duda el
funcionamiento del sistema electoral
creo que es Es peligroso en su posición
hacerlo porque de alguna u otra manera
sus seguidores a través de redes
sociales están empezando a cuestionar
que en caso de que llegue a ganar lulas
y continúa esta tendencia que nos han
mostrado las encuestas de que llegue a
ganar posiblemente Lula da Silva pues la
pregunta es si realmente
bolsonaro va a aceptar el resultado en
caso de que gane Lula Y como dijo Lula
esta semana lo va a llamar a felicitar o
no y pues viendo titulares a lo largo de
esta semana La pregunta era si Brasil va
a ser en el va a tener el mismo 6 de
enero que tuvo Estados Unidos con Donald
Trump y aquí pues la respuesta va a ser
que si sin duda Va a haber un ambiente
de mucha atención de mucha expectativa
de incertidumbre frente a qué va a ser
bolsonaro con ese resultado si le Es
favorable a Lula Pues no lo sabemos
Realmente si si lo va a aceptar o no lo
que sí es que aquí hay un factor
importante que hay que tener presente y
es que la diferencia con Estados Unidos
Pues es que el rol de los militares no
es tan importante o no están digamos
están intervencionista como lo puede ser
en Brasil ese es un factor que puede ser
diferenciador y esperemos Pues que
evidentemente triunfe el sistema
electoral y triunfren las instituciones
en Brasil porque no se puede poner en
tela de juicio ni ni ni mucho menos
afectar la salud de la democracia en el
país más grande
en términos económicos en términos de
población y en términos de tamaño de la
región ese clima de atención que usted
menciona ya le voy a dar la palabra a
Leonardo podría materializarse en
violencia como hemos visto durante esta
campaña electoral Bueno pues como lo
mencionamos al principio del programa lo
que estamos viendo Es que Hay demasiadas
emociones por parte del electorado se
está haciendo un llamado como a esa
emotividad que lamentablemente pues ha
derivado en algunos hechos de violencia
que no son generalizados evidentemente
pero que de alguna forma Pues sí no se
habían visto antes eso es lo que hace
que éstas sean unas elecciones pues tan
atípicas y que sean unas elecciones con
un grado de tensión tan alto entonces
pues creo que que va a ser importante
ver qué va a pasar el domingo